vous avez été chanté plus petite ville
très bourgeoise très calme très
tranquille plutôt du genre à tricoter
pour ses petits neveux ou où les enfants
du voisinage vd côté amusant chez elle
même très riche elle prenait sa rolls
los angeles puis eux demandé à son
chauffeur de l'emmener au supermarché le
moins cher
la gentillesse suel jamais je lui ai
entendu dire un mot désagréable sur un
autre artiste la conscience
professionnelle dans sa loge une heure
avant le concert toujours toujours pas
d'histoire d'alcool de drogue
rien rien real limpidité total très très
grande dame et je crois que c'est elle
qui finalement dans ce siècle dans
l'illustration que la données du
répertoire de la chanson aussi bien de
chansons populaires que la chanson
depuis jazz bien c'est le monument quoi
c'est la référence pour des siècles
[Musique]